It's no secret that Netflix is a big spender.
In 2017 alone, the streaming service dropped
$6.3 billion on original and acquired programming
- demolishing the video content budgets of
Viacom, Amazon, CBS, Apple, and Facebook.
But the lion's share of Netflix's budget,
of course, goes to original programming.
And to do that, the company has signed off
on some seriously extravagant series.
But which are the most expensive shows Netflix
has ever produced?
We've got your numbers.
Hemlock Grove
American creature-killer series Hemlock Grove
was supposed to be a surefire hit for Netflix.
But it ended up being little more than an
average show with a hefty price tag.
"Is there something you wanna tell me?"
"I'm about to do things I don't want to.
But sooner or later I'm gonna have to give
in."
When it premiered in 2013, Hemlock Grove ranked
among Netflix's most expensive shows to date,
reportedly costing $40 million for Season
One's 13 episodes - far more than most major
television networks are willing to shell out
for even a 22-episode run.
"Your entire bloodline's about to become extinct."
The series received a less-than-stellar critical
reception, though it did manage to garner
a dedicated fan-base which ultimately kept
the show alive for two additional seasons
before Netflix pulled the plug.
Orange is the New Black
As one of Netflix's most well-known and widely
acclaimed series, it's not surprising that
Orange Is the New Black ranks among the most
expensive offerings on the platform.
"These are complicated ladies in a complicated
place."
According to Peter Micelli, former co-head
of TV at CAA, the show runs just under $4
million per episode.
But investing in the screen rights to Piper
Kerman's memoir of the same name has paid
massive dividends for Netflix - in awards,
and worldwide brand recognition.
"We're gonna be super famous.
Don't forget to smeyes."
House of Cards
At the time of its creation, political thriller
House of Cards set a new standard for Netflix
- for quality, as well as production costs.
Former star and executive producer Kevin Spacey
once said production reportedly spent $100
million on the first season alone.
"We don't submit to terror.
We make the terror."
As the show closes in on its sixth and final
season, sans Spacey, in late 2018 - the series
will go down as a hit for the platform.
Netflix reportedly upped their subscriber
count by at least 27.5 million when House
of Cards debuted in 2013 - with the ultra-popular
political drama playing a major role in the
streaming service winning their fans' vote.
"We're just getting started."
Seinfeld's comedy
Netflix isn't just shelling out for high-profile
original series.
It's also forking it over for original stand-up,
as well.
And no deal was more expensive than the one
they made with Jerry Seinfeld.
"Would I have been funny if I grew up in Peoria
in a whorehouse, raised by prostitutes?
Absolutely.
But this is what I had to work with."
Netflix reportedly paid Seinfeld a staggering
$100 million for a pair of stand-up specials,
bundled with the streaming rights to his hit
web series Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee.
But the platform was happy to pay Seinfeld's
lofty premium.
Netflix's chief content officer, Ted Sarandos,
told Deadline,
"Jerry is known the world over as both a great
TV innovator and beloved comic voice.
We are incredibly proud to welcome him to
the Netflix comedy family."
"You excited?"
"I wouldn't say I'm excited, but I'm looking
forward to it."
The Get Down
Baz Luhrmann and Stephen Adly Guirgis' South
Bronx musical drama, The Get Down, caused
a lot of tension between Sony Pictures Television
and Netflix.
According to Variety, the show's two-and-a-half
year production saw two showrunners and a
whole slew of writers come and go - allegedly
due to Luhrmann's involvement.
A money-burning budget coupled with a lack
of actual filming saw Sony get fed up quickly,
but Netflix's Sarandos refused to greenlight
development until Luhrmann agreed to direct
the series from start to finish.
"The borough where I'm from ain't the slums.
We got kings.
And that's what I'll be.
My friends and me."
When The Get Down's 12-episode season finally
wrapped, production reportedly ended up costing
at least $120 million - and possibly more
than $190 million, all in - making it one
of the most expensive shows in television
history.
[scream]
But while it was canceled after its first
season, Netflix's VP of original content,
Cindy Holland, told Variety,
"We're about supporting our artists and supporting
their vision.
Working with Baz and his team was one of the
most rewarding experiences of my life."
The Crown
Netflix's historical drama The Crown tells
the biographical story of Queen Elizabeth
II - and boasts production costs that would
make the real royal family tighten their corsets.
"What do you want, a degree?
No one wants a college lecturer as sovereign.
They want a queen."
The show's first season alone reportedly cost
a record-setting $130 million in 2016.
Although show creator Peter Morgan thinks
that estimation is closer to the total cost
for the first two seasons, that still equates
to a whopping $6.5 to $13 million per hour-long
episode.
Helping drive up production costs was the
flawless recreation of Queen Elizabeth's wedding
dress - which cost approximately $37,000.
"We had teams of six people working for six
weeks, just embroidering the train and the
dress."
That, and someone had to sign off on a life-size
replica of Buckingham Palace.
Altered Carbon
Debuting in February 2018, dystopian cyberpunk
series Altered Carbon is rumored to be one
of Netflix's most expensive shows.
"You've been provided with this body, which
came equipped with military-grade neuro-chem,
and combat muscle memory."
Based on the 2002 novel by Richard K. Morgan,
Altered Carbon remained in development for
nearly a decade and a half.
Originally optioned by Warner Brothers, the
show began its expensive march to Netflix's
lineup once Terminator Genisys screenwriter
Laeta Kalogridis - and Games of Thrones director
Miguel Sapochnik - signed on.
The exact cost of Altered Carbon's production
remains a conservatively estimated $7 million
per episode.
However, Kalogridis told THR,
"That number is really funny.
I feel comfortable saying that that number
is not correct.
I would say it's inaccurate."
Regardless of how off the first season's $70
million estimate may be, if this show gets
its second season, it'll likely be breaking
the bank as one of Netflix's most expensive
shows ever.
"I thought you'd be bigger.
They made me bring all this backup."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!